as far as I'm concerned he won't be back
please not low on president of the
University
the kids that are buying hip-hop are
gangsta rap is mark one of those two got
more they don't want to call it it's a
wide audience and they hear this over
and over again so do they hear this at
home well chances are good no they heard
a lot of this from guys like this or now
I can shop the state of Oklahoma had
some issues that we need to talk about
and we've done that and this is just the
beginning of a great conversation I'm
incredibly ashamed of myself and we beg
your forgiveness as well as the
forgiveness of everyone I've hurt with
the words that come from my mouth
you